when nato was founded uh more than 75
years ago its members made a commitment
to collective security that was unlike
anything
in previous history
and when the berlin wall fell the people
of europe made clear that they wanted
their freedom
and their security to be inextricably
tied together
and that's why
nato agreed that any country
should be free to pursue the security
alliances that it that country chose
and we must resist we must oppose any
return to the days when the fates of
nations are decided over their heads by
a handful of great powers
and i want to stress that this is not
just
about russia just as nato itself is not
just about russia of course not
this is about upholding the founding
principles of an alliance which perhaps
more than any other institution has
brought stability and peace prosperity
to the world
and
that must be the bedrock of our
diplomatic efforts
the uk's commitment to european security
is unconditional
and immovable
we have the biggest defense budget in
europe and the second largest in nato
we've contributed more troops than any
other ally to nato's enhanced forward
presence
and today i've agreed with the secretary
general a package of support
to strengthen further our collective
security sending troops planes and ships
to defend nato from north to south
earlier this week i met the prime
minister of lithuania i'll be traveling
shortly to poland and
these are countries
where every day
the population wakes
with
an acute awareness
of the threat just
across their border and they are
countries whose voices and views must be
at the heart of every discussion we have
because
i believe that if we
can keep a strong grip
on the fundamentals those fundamental
principles that define
our alliance
and combine
strong
deterrence with patient diplomacy
then we can find a way through this
crisis
but
uh the stakes
are very high
and this is a very
dangerous moment
and at stake
are the rules that protect every nation
every nation
big and small